and we continue our series on the new
normal looking at how the pandemic is
dramatically changing our everyday lives
up now visits to medical offices dental
offices are reopening after months of
handling only emergencies but now all 50
states will allow routine dental care
but dentistry is considered one of the
highest risk professions for the
coronavirus our senior medical
correspondent dr. Tara Narula shows us
the unique challenges someone asked me
in January hey you ever think about
taking three months off from dentistry
and I'll be like yeah when I retired it
was never on my radar that we dr. Peter
Schatz is chairman of the Georgia Dental
Association's Cova 19 innovation Task
Force he's one of the people trying to
help dentists navigate complicated
guidance from the state OSHA and CDC on
how to reopen safely we were stood up to
help our members better understand the
complexities of the corona virus from
science research availability of PPE 90%
of dental offices in the u.s. were open
for elective care by the first week of
June but it won't be business as usual
so the traditional waiting for your
doctor's appointment inside the
reception area is gone we send a team
member out into the parking lot actually
the shooting temperature make sure that
they're not experiencing any illness
what makes dentistry so high-risk isn't
just proximity to patients mouths it's
the nature of the procedures themselves
what are some of the things that
generate the most aerosolization
of the virus so fillings root canals dr.
Kirk norvo co-chaired a covert ask force
for the American Dental Association
we're hand scaling now the teeth broader
than using the cavity on or the
ultrasonic scaler to create a safe as an
environment as we can the CDC recently
updated its guidelines to address
routine dental care stressing the
importance of PPE allowing downtime
between patients and prioritizing
emergency care but a number of high
genna's CBS News spoke with feel it's
still too soon
I'm telling all of my friends and family
do not go to the dentist it's probably
the worst most dangerous place you could
go right now just because of the nature
of the work with the aerosols dr. Schatz
and nor Bo disagree and worry delaying
care could lead to other health issues
the biggest risk in dentistry is
uncontrolled infections and those could
lead to systemic disease can aggravate
underlying problems I think a lot of
people at home are gonna be wondering is
it safe to go to the dentist I think
absolutely it's safe the biggest thing
I'd say is we're here for you we're back
in business we feel like they've got a
safe environment for our patients to
return to and dr. taryn Narula joins us
now for a broader look at the safety of
any and all visits to the doctor right
now and good morning doctor that's an
incredible piece at what look at look at
what dental officers are doing but
looking more broadly what should any
medical office be doing - welcome
patients safely well Tony there's a lot
that offices can do to not only make
patients feel safe but also to actually
protect them the first thing really
starts with screening patients on the
phone so having a nurse or nurse
practitioner call and ask about fever or
any symptoms and that might triage them
in a different direction then when they
show up to the office really separating
anybody who's sick from the well quickly
putting someone with any sort of
respiratory or fever symptoms into their
own room and keeping that one room for
sick patients and the rest of the room
for healthier ones in addition the
waiting room that we're used to is gonna
look very different so chairs will be
placed six feet apart as you saw on the
package many patients may be asked to
wait in their car until they get a text
message any toys or magazines or flyers
will really be removed from waiting
rooms you'll see lots of Plexiglas
barriers lots of sanitizer tissues waste
baskets and then we are not going to
probably be allowing non-essential
visitors with patients so those days
where you brought your whole family with
you into the room it's really gonna be
limited to just the patient yeah so as
patients we should be asking questions
about whether these things are in place
but another question we'll be asking
ourselves is how do we prioritize
different visits we may have what goes
first what second one third
that's a great question and the first
thing to do is really talk to your
doctor and figure out what kind of a
patient are you do you have any chronic
medical conditions any urgent symptoms
do you need any vaccinations or any
important screening tests that might say
you should come in now and not put it
off on the other hand if you're someone
who's healthy and it's a routine checkup
you may be able to wait you should
certainly ask the office about what
their protocol is and that good
communication is really important and
importantly you should ask about
telehealth telemedicine is really
something that's taken off we've been
using it a lot I have to say I've been
pleasantly surprised by how well and how
efficient it is and patients really like
that visual one-on-one encounter yeah I
had a telehealth appointment for baby
Teddy just a couple weeks ago and it
worked perfectly so dr. Turner Ulla
thank you very much for the telehealth
endorsement it can work and the broader
recommendations are wonderful as well